dieser Mann kämpft für die
Unabhängigkeit der Justiz in seinem
Heimatland Polen Richter igortulea ist
inzwischen zu einer regelrechten
Symbolfigur geworden spontan kommt eine
fremde Frau auf ihn zu sie will ihm
danken und gratulieren für seine Dienste
igorea stellt sich schon seit Jahren
auch offen gegen die Regierung und
rückte ins Visier der
Nationalkonservativen Regierungspartei
peace
to Lea wurde vorgeworfen sich strafbar
gemacht zu haben weil er 2017 bei der
Urteilsverkündung in einem für die
Regierung unangenehmen Verfahren
Medienvertreter zugelassen hatte
ich war über zweieinhalb Jahre nicht in
der Lage meinen Job zu machen weil ich
rechtswidrig suspendiert wurde
seit ein paar Monaten darf ich wieder
urteilen
also erledige ich auch meine Arbeit
obwohl ich das Gefühl habe auf einem
Pulverfass zu sitzen
es kann immer noch alles passieren
[Musik]
der heute 52-Jährige wehrt sich gegen
seine Suspendierung und die Justizreform
der Regierung er wird zu einer lauten
proteststimme in Polen
eigentlich ist das die Schuld der
Politiker weil sie versucht haben sich
der Justiz zu bemächtigen
durch diesen dreisten Diebstahl und
Angriff auf die Werte einer unabhängigen
Justiz haben sie uns Richter gegen
unseren Willen in die Welt der Politik
hineingezogen
und auf einmal ist er ein berühmter
Richter der sich zu Wehr setzt und dafür
auch angefeindet wird
angefangen hat es mit verbalen Attacken
in letzter Zeit wurde ich aber durchaus
auch mal körperlich angegangen wenn ich
auf der Straße unterwegs bin ist es
üblich dass mich jemand käuflich oder
Verräter nennt
die Gesellschaft in Polen ist gespalten
die Stimmung aufgeheizt auf dem Weg zu
einer großen Kundgebung der Opposition
Anfang Juni werden wir selbst Zeuge
davon
ihr seid alle Verräter ihr verkauft
Polen an Moskau und Berlin wacht endlich
auf
sie verraten das Land hier die Farben
Polens haben sie mehr Respekt für unser
Land
ihr verratet Polen ihr seid die Verräter
hunderttausende strömen auf die Straßen
sie wollen ihrem Ärger Luft machen ihr
Unmut wird verstärkt durch ein neues
Gesetz das sieht eine Kommission vor die
untersuchen soll ob die polnische
Politik der vergangenen Jahre so durch
Russland beeinflusst wurde dass sie
nicht mehr im Wulle Polens gehandelt hat
die Pies sagt es geht dabei um Russland
die Opposition sagt es geht um sie ihre
Befürchtung Kritiker sollen gezielt
geschwächt werden
inmitten der Menschenmenge treffen wir
auch Familie subjektschaf Olga und piota
sind mit ihrem vierjährigen Sohn
Christoph gekommen und haben eine klare
Meinung
die Regierung hat einfach Angst und
sucht nach jeder Möglichkeit die Polen
in bessere und schlechtere zu
unterteilen damit die besseren am Ende
gewinnen und der Pies helfen weiter zu
regieren und in Polen weiter das zu tun
was sie in den letzten acht Jahren
gemacht haben
peinlich nennen sie die Gesetze die die
peace einführt dazu gehören die
russlandkommission und die Justizreform
letztere verstößt nachweislich gegen EU
Recht denn sie gefährdet die
Unabhängigkeit der gerichtet Mutter Olga
macht sich Gedanken wie es weitergeht
wenn es bei den Wahlen im Herbst keinen
Machtwechsel gibt
jetzt gehen sie gegen den
Oppositionsführer vor aber in jedem
Moment könnte es einen von uns treffen
wir könnten ohne echten Prozess und ohne
die Möglichkeit der Berufung verurteilt
werden
auch mirik und voltig sind hier
unterwegs zum ersten Mal nehmen Sie an
einer solchen Kundgebung teilen sie
treiben viele Sorgen um
Gleichheit
Freiheit Toleranz das Leben nach dem
Gesetz die Achtung der Verfassung
eigentlich wird hier nichts mehr
wirklich respektiert
seit einem Jahr sind die beiden
verheiratet auch wegen ihrer sexuellen
orientierungsstoßen die in Polen immer
wieder auf Probleme und Anfeindungen an
die jetzige Regierung haben sie einen
deutlichen Appell
öffnen Sie Ihren Geist wieder auch wenn
Sie wahrscheinlich seit Jahrzehnten nur
noch in ihrer eigenen Welt leben es gibt
für sie doch nur noch eine Perspektive
fangen sie an wieder mit den Menschen zu
reden wirklich auf sie zuzugehen zeigen
sie uns dass sie etwas Gutes wollen
ein Appell den viele auf Warschau
Straßen wohl auch unterschrieben hätten
sie alle eint die Befürchtung dass sich
Polen immer weiter von einer
demokratischen Staatsordnung entfernt
erst recht mit Blick auf die neue
russlandkommission sagt ein bekennender
Kritiker
da entsteht ein sehr politisches Gremium
das im Grunde genommen ohne Konsequenzen
jedem die politische Teilhabe entziehen
kann und das ist furchtbar gefährlich so
hat es nicht einmal im späten
Kommunismus in Polen funktioniert
Unabhängigkeit der Gerichte in Polen
massiv gefährdet
wir haben es in meinem Land inzwischen
nicht mehr mit einer liberalen
Demokratie zu tun sondern mit einer Art
fassadendemokratie
denn ja wir haben einige Institutionen
wir haben Gerichte die sind aber nicht
völlig unabhängig wir haben einen
Verfassungsgericht das kein
Verfassungsgericht ist und wir haben
Wahlen die nicht völlig fair sind
sich bewusst dass er mit seinem Protest
ein hohes Risiko eingeht und doch wird
er sich wie viele andere Menschen in
Polen weiter für die Rechtsstaatlichkeit
im Land einsetzen und für eine wehrhafte
Demokratie kämpfen